[Musique]
au décrypteurs on se fait souvent posé
la question mais comment ça se fait que
telle ou telle personne croit en telle
ou telle théorie conspirationniste ou
complotistes bouchra wathiq on te
retrouves parce que tu t'es pencher dans
le cadre de l'émission découverte sur
nos cerveaux est la question centrale de
ta démarche est pourquoi notre cerveau
voir des complots partout mais en fait
c'est parce qu'on a évolué comme ça
depuis la préhistoire
alors il faut comprendre que autrefois
le si on remonte à plusieurs milliers
d'années
il y avait beaucoup plus de complot dans
les sociétés qu'aujourd'hui et quand je
dis complot je veux pas dire dans le
sens on est dirigée par une société
secrète de les armer vraiment dans le
sens tout simple de les tribus voisines
complotaient pour voler des ressources
pour voler de la nourriture à une autre
tribu et à ce niveau là mais ni complot
c'était une menace pour l'humain ce qui
fait qu on a évolué à vraiment être très
à l'affût à détecter les complots avant
même qu'ils se concrétisent c'était
vraiment un avantage pour notre survie
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans la
société moderne et même depuis quelques
siècles
il ya beaucoup moins de complot les
sociétés / - tribales
donc la société a changé le problème
c'est que notre cerveau elle n'a pas pu
évoluer lui en quelques siècles
seulement
donc on est tous restés avec ses
réflexes préhistorique de vraiment être
à l'affût d'avoir l'oeil ouvert pour
voir tous les complots potentiel alors
justement restons dans ce contexte qui
est le nôtre avec le cerveau qui est le
nôtre
qu'est ce qui se passe ce bouchra dans
la tête d'une personne
conspirationnistes est ce que la science
s'est épanché là dessus en effet mais on
voit certaines zones du cerveau s'active
certains biais qu'on le tous en fait à
l'intérieur de notre cerveau mais
chez certaines personnes ça va s'activer
plus que chez d'autres
premièrement quand on a peur notre
cerveau se met en mode de chercher des
moyens pour faire face au danger
la première chose que le cerveau à faire
c'est de chercher la cause de ce danger
là et on a bien qui nous amène à penser
qu'une cause intentionnels qui est une
cause qui a été créée par quelques
plutôt que de se dire ben c'est un
hasard si un accident on a aussi
tendance à penser que les gens autour de
nous ont potentiellement des mauvaises
intentions mais dans le cas de la kfw 19
mai ça fait que beaucoup de gens vont se
dire bon bill gates qui investit dans la
recherche sur les pandémies il doit
avoir des mauvaises intentions
donc ça aussi c'est un autre de nos
biens et finalement les gens ont
vraiment tendance à chercher à faire des
liens entre des choses qui n'ont pas de
lien évident entre eux mais ça amène
parfois certaines personnes à se dire tu
la 5g vient d'apparaître à peu près en
même temps que la coc u19
est ce qu'un lien entre les deux et il
ya une recherche assez intéressante qui
démontre que les gens qui voient des
peintures abstraites et qui sont
capables de voir des formes concrètes
dans ses toiles abstraites des sont plus
enclins à croire à des théories du
complot comme quoi un cerveau qui fait
plus de liens est un cerveau plus
conspirationnistes et puis une fois
qu'on met le doigt dans l'engrenage
qu'on croit une théorie du complot
on a tendance à précieux à croire à
plusieurs autres théories